Великобританія планує вийти з Євросоюзу
29 березня 2019 року – цю дату і навіть точний час –
23тю годину на Гринвічем – уряд Великобританії
має намір затвердити законодавчо.
Але перемовники вибилися з графіку.
Спочатку передбачалося, що перший етап
переговорів – щодо умов виходу Великобританії
з Євросоюзу – завершиться до кінця цього року.
Потому почнеться другий етап – дискусія про
конкретні моделі подальших взаємовідносин.
Лондон сподівається якнайшвидше розпочати
обговорення угоди про вільну торгівлю і доступ
до європейського внутрішнього ринку.
А Брюсселю після ухвалення всіх рішень
знадобиться ще немало часу на ратифікацію
документів усіма країнами ЄС та Європарламентом.
Зокрема й через це зустріч 4 грудня між
представниками ЄС і Великобританії неодноразово
називали «останнім терміном» для визначення
позицій Лондона щодо спірних питань довкола Brexit.
Основні суперечки - навколо трьох пунктів.
Перший, і багато хто вважає його головним –
це сума компенсації, яку Лондон має виплатити за вихід із ЄС.
За розрахунками Єврокомісії, Великобританія
мусить виконувати свої фінансові зобов’язання до
2020 року, адже перебуваючи в складі ЄС, вона
пообіцяла брати участь у фінансуванні європейських
програм, розрахованих на цей період.
ЄС очікує від Лондона виплат у розмірі
близько шістдесяти мільярдів євро.
І хоча Тереза Мей, прем’єр-міністерка Великобританії,
заявляла, що не відмовляється від цих зобов’язань,
вона жодного разу не називала суму, яку готовий сплатити Лондон.
Друге ключове питання – це те, як зміняться права
громадян ЄС, які проживають в Об’єднаному Королівстві.
Йдеться про понад три мільйони людей.
В Брюсселі вимагають, щоб у тих громадян ЄС, які
вже понад 5 років проживають у Британії, з’явився
дозвіл на постійне проживання, а також можливість
отримувати соціальні та пенсійні виплати.
Третє ключове питання – облаштування кордону
між частиною Великобританії – Північною Ірландією
– і членом ЄС – Ірландією.
Наразі перетин цього кордону відбувається
непомітно, без блокпостів і перевірок документів.
Але після Brexit організувати прикордонний і митний
контроль на єдиній сухопутній ділянці кордону
ЄС і Британії буде непросто.
Зокрема, Дублін вимагає конкретних гарантій від
Лондона вже невдовзі – на саміті 14-15 грудня в Брюсселі.
Якщо все піде за планом, на саміті ухвалять рішення
про перехід до другого етапу перемов.